hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to another world's
quietest let's play now you may know my
personal history with I am bread it is a
game that deserves to be flayed alive on
the sacrificial altar
however I've received word the
development team is made a slightly less
stupid way to control yet inanimate
breath we've added a fresh new control
scheme called gamepad basic this will
make your bread a little easier to
control in case you were finding it too
crust raising so I'm going to take this
in with a modicum of love and we will
see oh we will see what we can of the
[ __ ] is bagel race oh no I remember I
remember bending you let us this looks
just as stupid as it was before
okay this is literally just as bad as it
once was
oh the memories are flooding back into
me now the horrors of which my past has
haunted me you Jim
there comes a time in everybody's life
when they must sacrifice for the greater
good and this is not that [ __ ] done
don't worry little controller I won't
break you unless you deserve to be
broken same goes for all of you let's
continue on our so long as we think the
most peaceful thoughts in the world we
will be okay we can persevere through
what are you how is that even what I
want you to do and just flop your stupid
floppy body over this yonder way and if
you [ __ ] oh you [ __ ] up
you [ __ ] up here comes a stabbing I
need you to question everything you have
ever done in your life yes throw the
bottle in anger
[Laughter]
if you listen closely enough you can
hear the anger neurons firing inside my
brain I'm the man of a considerable
patience and you bread I don't care how
many fingernail clippings I don't care
how many bandits how much AIDS you have
on you I will eat you I will eat all of
you not you guys I'm thinking that maybe
maybe I haven't activated the new
control scheme and then if there wasn't
no I was home I was on gamepad basic
these are literally no different there's
there's nothing different about this
okay
then is it the way that life is we can
beat this we can beat this cuz I believe
in me who believes in you and if we
believe in each other maybe we will go
shut the [ __ ] up what is that what is
that what is that glowing glory over
there could it be something that's going
to save me I don't know what that did oh
it gave me grip grips like the gods grip
like the gods that's not gonna help me
if it's just gonna be stupid like that
oh my head ability is a hundred percent
wait did it feel pity on me does it feel
pity on me and decide to give me what
Nintendo gives you when you fail a level
too much the goal didn't in Newquay suit
and that's what this is isn't it
I see your game why is it so hard to
crawl over a pair of pants they are
simple elegant creatures pants but you
can just get the [ __ ] over it and move
your bread ass over there this is the
life
[Music]
there we are now mMmmm I don't care if
this is pretty much cheating at this
point my bread seems to have grown so
far then that's okay because I Who am
NOT cheating i why am i going why am i
to be the underside of this you guys
don't understand how much I literally
hate there is nothing I feel inside my
soul for this [ __ ] game slow and
steady wins the race
slow and steady gets you punched in the
side the face or I am a golden God if I
don't get toasted in the light then
where do I go there is a freaking heat
iron right there is it on I don't think
it's on I'm going to get my bread a slid
in those slots
I need to get to the top of that dresser
and then throw my bread body off of it
excuse me breathing like a beast in your
ear it's the only thing I can do to stay
sane hmm flailing wildly I see something
I am very accustomed to in the middle of
the night Oh things are looking up for
markiplier if you know what I mean that
means I'm going up this seems impossible
and yet I have doesn't there we go I can
do this excuse the most pathetic launch
I've ever seen in my life
if you I saw my life flash before my
eyes I saw everything that I knew in LA
I saw everything that I knew and loved
being destroyed in front of me okay I
just have to get on this goddamn toaster
you see the arduous [ __ ] that I had
to go through just to get to this one
point how in the flip-flop in Flook
Dupin world would i've ever gone there
on my own just a little bit farther I
just hang like here floating like a flag
in the wind haunting and flaunting my
victory to everyone around me I will get
a lovely even toasting
why are you doing that why why why why
why why why why why why I asked you I
beg you I calls the heavens why why are
you doing that why are you doing that
just stop just beat up hold yourself
before I wreck you self you've yourself
you've I wreck you I will I will
literally kill you I got one side done
it's okay it's all right
I guess something that you going like
let hold the shard let go of the I
closed my eyes for one second and you
tried to betray me we have reached the
precipice
so much and you get into that iron and
you cook in the fires of Alf I hate you
with every fiber of my being
why have you stopped toasting
friend host like the bastard here you
are hmm
I have done it I am victorious I am the
greatest bread master to ever walk the
earth and anyone who disagrees with me
shall be punished severely with that
being said now I can bury this game the
annals of history not the anals of
history the annals with two ends and let
it be forgotten and my dead in the ocean
where it belongs in person down there
with chains unbreakable so thank you
everybody so much for watching and thank
you for joining me on another world's
quietest let's play let me know what you
think down in the comments below and as
always I will see you in the next video
buh-bye